show there's a there's a funny little
thing there that should say love show
all right well here we are my name is
Noel ye and this is I'm Cassie four
Hoops mckenny
thanks and uh we're here on Lo show with
a special guest host who's Cassie
tonight because Mikey is actually yeah
Mike's getting buff right now he's uh
getting strong if anybody has any advice
on this Loft show thing please let us
know because I'm kind of new to this
Google Hangout thing um so yeah so why
Loft show I was uh inspired by watching
the Techo chat group to maybe I don't
know have another chat and if you don't
know that chat you should check out
drex's Facebook or also his YouTube and
it's all on there what if you don't spin
po no while I don't know um interesting
for people who don't spin poy spin other
props you mean La show or you mean no
J's
uh I don't know I think if you're really
good at if you like math it probably
still be
interesting um but even if you're like a
lot of lot of theory and technique or
what's what's going on there I think
there's just a lot of talking uh about
like people speculating which I think is
a a necessary thing and I think that
it's definitely a place for people to
talk and express like that this one's
trying to be more laid-back um in a
certain capacity and so yeah that's sort
of why I started L show and this is the
first one and really excited and uh who
is L show would be another question well
you probably my name is Noel ye I uh I
actually teach science to kids during
the day do crazy science experiments
blowing stuff up well sometimes and and
my my nighttime job I do a lot of
producing of events and some other
things so yeah that's kind of
my my bio this is Cassie what do you do
Cassie I'm Cassie I am a mini Hooper
and a hand Stander and
a uh what else a hoook juggler and um
who you learning hoop juggling from I am
actually taking hoop juggling lessons
with Kyle Johnson if You' ever heard of
I don't know Kyle Johnson know if heard
of him but he's awesome he been teaching
me a lot of stuff I'm learning the three
hoop roll forwards and backwards right
now and I can't do it all the way I can
only do two on each side but uh working
on it nice and um yeah live here at the
Vulcan and train fulltime it's
awesome nice I have a particularly
squeaky chair yeah you do I was if you
can't hear that that's uh my chair
squeaky um and Mikey actually so it's
called Loft show because I live in a
loft bed which will show you Vulcan lofs
Vulcan Lofts if you know that Facebook
group is pretty good
too but uh yeah this is a loft back here
um Mikey sleeps on the top there and
then I sleep on the bottom there and yes
Mikey is a phenomenal spinner and I spin
quite a bit too and we share a love of
spinning and apparently sleeping in a
LOF bed yeah two 30-year-old men living
in a queen size bunk bed it's pretty
awesome yeah it's uh living the dream
definitely definitely definitely nice
I'm also traveling a lot and I work
pretty much
non-stop yeah that's true so first thing
we were to talk about today was the vtg
app uh what is the VT G Cassie I've
heard this on the internet Techo chat
and I have no idea if people are
watching this now but Techo chat what is
vtg uh the vtg is the Vulcan Tech gospel
which is a a
comprehensive collection of prop
manipulation Tech um it's pretty it's
pretty nice to have something all
together that's gives you a lot of
information and allows you to continue
to learn on your own too so I'm I'm
really into it nice vtg stands for
Vulcan Tech gospel and uh yeah for me
it's sort of been a long process I think
it kind of started wrote it wow what a
who wrote question I would say we've all
written it over the years of spinning
all of us that have put it together
these put it together uh the first sort
of inception of it boy it's really very
complicated I would
say a long time ago I don't know when
things happened would be a bigger
question but I was really into something
called transition Theory and you can
check out a video on my YouTube it's
this really weird name uali i d a l i
comes from Dune comes from Dune if you
know it you're awesome if you don't
don't worry about it but
uh anyways um way back in the day I made
a transition Theory video and um from
there Brian and Lor and Dave and bunch
of others kind of just went at it and
like everybody working and crazy
different pockets and from that there's
a lot of really cool manipulatives from
Vulcan Tech gospel one if you've seen
that which is basically um for clubs but
you can do it with po it would be cat
Hoops Mini Hoops would be a good one too
I don't really do static props yeah I
don't do Mini Hoops but Mike no no no no
these guys are like crazy there's no way
but I play with them a little bit but uh
yeah in in Vulcan te go one transition
the was applied and that's where the 24
Club hybrid sequence came out of there
was a lot of Brian lur and T um working
on that and then tank and I actually
then volte gospel I designed um based
off of Brian's first drawing and then
there's a couple documents in there and
that's all about the one one if you
don't know what that means just give you
a little breakdown maybe this is like
confusing thing this is awesome so the
like if I were to write one colon one
maybe you've seen this on
it's like massively confusing and like
something like this right look no you
can't draw write it bigger no man all
right so
one colon one see that's all that's all
let me right for you whatever okay she
right one go in one what that means is
like we actually started by uh thinking
about when you do flowers I think a lot
of people know that your hand does like
a circle and your prop does a little
circle too and um the combinations of
those is what yields timing Direction
you know two objects spinning around on
a circle and so in the beginning we sort
of had the idea that you know it gets
really confusing because the order of
this changes for a lot of people but we
started with hand and prop you can see
that it's like one one hand prop and uh
like that's how we started and that
means one prop rotation for every one
hand rotation so like a cat ey does that
Cat ey isolations extensions yeah
there's a iCal cat eye here's a little
isolation with this Sharpie oh man look
sharp isolation I toally just wrote on
myself that actually all but uh and in
that basically that's where btg1 was
born out of strangely we've actually
been switching the order because it
sounds cooler because Wulan Tech gospel
2 is about and is about the 31 and what
31 is exciting because that's three
proper rations for every hand rotation
but if both hands are doing a pattern
that does that you can maintain timing
and direction by changing speeds and
doing different things you can't really
maintain time and direction in the same
way but yeah so that VTech gospel 2 and
actually what I mentioned it is if you
guys are into it at all and you have an
Android phone not an iPhone or an iPad
sorry Apple users yeah you can download
the app that I uh one of my co-workers
is a amazing I know he's just really
good at making apps and he made this uh
Vulcan TCH see how you got that done
that's pretty super impressive it pretty
awesome um it's based off the Matrix
that's in Vulcan Tech gospel 2 that tank
made and um I would show it you on the
phone me and Cassie are playing with see
we could show you it but you can't you
can go to the Google Play Store and
download the Volcan Tech gospel app but
is it free it is free actually and if
you if you download it you could like
like it or put some stars on it or
something oh and also Zach actually Zach
boier he's my roommate he actually lives
below Loft like how you have to think
about how to say his last same well no
it's just like a epic Hooper he just
hasn't he is pretty epic he's like
jumping through hoops and doing crazy
stuff pretty wild but um yeah Zack buer
made the designs actually the the little
patterns for Vulcan te gospel 2 that are
in the app oh and my friend Kevin nck
made the actual app itself and and what
about the tell what it usest talk about
okay so well basically all you do is
select the timing direction from the
little list here and then you would the
patterns that are possible in that
timing Direction in the 31 right which
is a diamond anti- spin a box anti spin
horizontal two pedal in spin thing and
then a vertical two pedal in spin thing
the patterns that are possible show up
and now it's not in the app yet but in
the next update you actually click on
the little thing and uh an animation
pops up that actually alien John made so
awesome which is really really cool a
robot pois spinner it's perfect and
right now Vulcan de gospel is sort of an
open source project and we're trying to
figure out how we can keep making this
app as we don't pay ourselves maybe
crowdfunding for the app or something I
have no idea but basically we need to
figure out next levels of the app
because getting all the there's 40
patterns so there's 40 animations in the
app itself it's about 10 Megs is and
John and Kevin worked hard to make sure
it was stayed small but yeah it's really
awesome it's so cool I love the
app all right what's next what's next
yeah
uh Festival season is upon
us first Festival what's your first
Festival flame Festival in you're not
going to Humble um that is questionable
I may haveing I may have to work humble
is so one of the best juggling festivals
yeah that's my second favorite I'm gonna
say it that I've been to what was your
first mad skills in BC was so much fun
the the level of talent there and the
fun that those kids have is amazing they
have a lot of fun they do but the humble
kids have a lot of fun too yeah but I
think in a different way it's like a
lovey-dovey hippie way well it's really
cool that the Mad Skills guys have this
baller Warehouse yeah they have a v a
Vulcan but it's clean it's a clean oh
it's so amazing and it's you look
outside and there's like trees and you
know there's no dogs barking at you or
cops giving you dirty look what you
trying to say about the vul you know
what right inside's nice but you know
what I mean yeah but they also have like
their space is like located I don't know
three blocks from the Olympic Park the
Olympics in Vancouver and there's like
these cool structures and it's pretty
nice out there yeah but I'm trying to
get to Humble I really I I may have to
work that weekend but we'll see what
happens but yeah I'm definitely going to
Flame I just got my plan ticket
yesterday nice where's flame uh flames
in Lafayette is that what it's called
Georgia town it's right outside of
Atlanta about 45 minutes outside of
Atlanta It's a Cherokee Farm yeah where
they have the Alchemy Aly so they have a
really pretty Lake and um it's cool it's
a it's pretty small Festival about 300
people know ask um yeah around there and
um there's tons of instructors this year
there's almost 70 instructors on the
list so much talent it's gonna be really
really fun Kyle's gonna be there that we
were talking about earlier um aen alen's
gonna be there gonna be there Noel's
gonna be there I'll be there Zach will
be there all of the homies downstairs no
way yeah Zach's going to Flame no I
think he's going he bought a ticket to
kinetic no no I'm pretty sure he's going
but then what else anyway it's really
cool the place that we could hang out
before the festival the kinetic Hive is
a really amazing spot around if you see
this you're awesome and your space is
awesome she has a really cool space it's
a little um warehouse space as well with
all sorts of's name the kinetic Hive
kinetic Hive it's really nice really
cool it's fun to stay there she's got
really cute kitties she does have cats
um but yeah Flame is going to be awesome
you're coming yes I am I have yet to
purchase my ticket oh we should have
done that together all of us fun yeah
yeah well so humble juggling Festival
let's talk about humble a little bit
humble juggling Festival is located in
Arcada California and uh if you don't
know where Arcada is it's basically
people like to gag it's six hours from
everywhere it's like the joke about
humble just letting you know it's sort
of located six hours from every
direction pretty much you could be near
there so also Hsu now something else I
learned is that the the joke they call
it is Hills and stairs
University which makes a lot of sense
when you go there because it's kind of
like completely on the hillside totally
but uh it's really beautiful in ourada
and I really like Los Bagels you been
there Los Bagels is is awesome this is
the snack man I don't know Noel's always
eating something and is the first person
to offer you some really delicious Red
Vines or peanut butter filed pretzels or
those little fruit leather strips yeah I
do like snacks quite a bit I do you
would know where The Bagel Spot is well
it's l Bagel it's so good man it's
delicious but uh yeah hum's free that's
the really is free Festival it's is the
show free no no the show may be like 10
or15 pretty sure it's the humble
juggling Society is what you want to
look up The Humble juggling
Society it's gonna oh you should go you
should go and I feel like I don't know
last year their Friday night was in a
smaller gym they had a crazy Renegade we
can't talk about it too much but the
Renegade was pretty awesome last year
pretty wild Vancouver Mad Skills people
fully represented just in support to
their awesome Festival if you don't know
what Mad Skills is that's that Festival
in Vancouver we were talking about that
U Ally Yuki Chris I'm probably missing
lots of people Dawn lots of people that
help out do that show and so yeah that's
awesome and what else is coming up we
got flame I'm not going to a bunch of
these but there's spin Summit isn't
there there is spin Summit I'm teaching
at that as well where is that's
in Denver outside of Denver I think it's
either in Golden or another suburb of
Denver but it's really beautiful there
it's in the in the mountains and um
really nice people and it's kind of a
smaller Festival but um I've never been
so I can't talk too much about it but
it'll be a weekend thing and the end of
the weekend they do a a summit up a 14er
and then have a spin Jam nice so that
should be fun and exhausting I know
Canyon is some he's a nice guy yeah
Canyon will be Canyon and Danielle um
Canyon Walker and Daniel de for the
festival Danielle's a really good Hooper
and K's a PO spinner and he's a beast
he's put out some pretty good videos at
the Fun Teaching there grian markk
stamp's out there mark St Mark St that's
right awesome really good contact ugler
if you don't know him check him about
and I know he's a he helps do something
at the boulder C he actually lives there
he has um there's an apartment upstairs
and it's this big barn um that it's huge
it has so many aerial apparatuses and
it's got three different practice spaces
and he lives there and helps run it and
his rent I don't think he pays rent but
he just like runs the space and has this
awesome space it's really good actually
uh beautiful there I actually recorded
the contact staff DVD if you guys have
ever seen the Vulcan DVD contact staff
DVD I recorded that in with rainbow
Michael with rainbow Michael actually in
that space uh oh
we did that in that space and what's
funny is I have two distinct memories of
the space number one is that there's a
sign outside on the rocks that says
beware of snakes like in this like rock
thing it is in the middle of a field
it's pretty funny and then there was
another thing where the water in the
place like they get their water from
like a sulfuric well or something and
the water smells like sulfur they're
like dying of thirst after doing all
this contact St and it just smelled like
eggs TR to drink water
delicious okay oh so what else Festival
season anything else coming up beyond
that let's see we have in Lucidity is
happening the same weekend as flame I
think oh I would love to go to Lucidity
and I know that my our friends Rao and
Ryan Williams are a part of that yep um
that's cool where is Lucidity I think
it's in La is it in or around La at the
centa I don't know where it is but you
should check it out we went to luny
Mikey and I but we should be is I think
if it's in the same spot that's an
awesome spot it's like above it above
Santa Barbara more of a a music movement
Fusion Festival yeah they had a lot of
DJ there's a lot of DJ and unfortunately
when I was there they actually the fire
at lunacy not Lucidity which is I guess
separate I think they're run by the same
people but
differents think I don't know about that
feel like they might be separate
festivals but either way the fire Circle
closed early so I
wonder fire this year but um let's see
okay let's go to our last topic which is
a flow show and tell so maybe we should
talk about the flow show well the flow
show is a it's like a showcase maybe
you've heard about it a little bit and
um it happens in San Francisco this will
be its fifth year and the flow show is h
a project of the seed fun seed fund the
fund the flow Arts which is a nonprofit
um that's uh you can check it out fun
theflow arts.org and um yeah who runs
that um con is the executive I can't
exactly identify each role but there's a
board of people that KH one of the board
members and Khan does out most a lot of
the work for the also awesome awesome
Hooper he's an awesome he's a such an
awesome totally my men he was one of the
first people I watched of his videos and
was like I want to do that like that guy
Bo it out that guy's like my mentor that
guy's crazy that guy is like so calm and
does so many crazy things that was he's
a pretty amazing guy good one but the
flow show is like a show with spinners
and to Spinners and stuff and this year
will be its fifth year and it's at dance
Mission theater on 24th Mission like in
San Francisco yeah right across from the
BART which is really convenient just get
off a 24 Street just walk across the
street and um we're actually Cassie and
I are making routines for the flow show
this year in San Francisco and the
website in case you forgot is theow
show.org and uh yeah C we making
routines and we do this thing for the
flow show where we actually get together
and we show our routines to everybody
where we get in a room and we run our
routines and then yeah and then we all
get feedback on those routines and
Cassie and I were just talking about
that before you get going yeah I'm I'm
really nervous about it this is my only
the second performance that I've ever
done that I have choreographed and put
thought into it past I'm going to buy
this outfit and spin fire this person's
private party where is it um at Florida
flow Fest which is in South Florida and
run by my good friend Cassandra tanom um
really sweet Festival if you're on the
East Coast um but yeah I have been
working really hard on this routine and
I'm just nervous because you did the
level of talent in the flow show and the
people that are in it um is is just Next
Level so I'm nervous um um it's the same
song and the same same concept or the
same feel but it's uh completely
different nice I haven't been able to
see her routine I've seen like chunk of
it do have the whole thing I don't I
didn't ask anyone to record it I I'm I
it was a rookie mistake I didn't ask
anyone to record it and the person who
record was recording their battery died
you know not even halfway through so I
don't even know what it looks like um
but I did just two Hoops in that routine
the whole way through we do three and
this routine I I have a one hoop two ho
and three ho section the routine so um
yeah it'll be good I'm I'm excited but
I'm super nervous I'm kind of more
nervous for the flow Show and Tell than
I am for the actual performance well
it's good at the flow show and tell
because nobody talks that's good they
just write their observation no it's not
you just don't know who wrote it it just
helps just like there's no conversation
yeah I don't know you don't have to
convince anybody anything you just get
the feedback and you step away and if
you have like more go from there I'm
sure it'll be helpful the last time like
when you guys re critiqued my routine
that was so nerve-wracking but it was it
was what I needed to hear and I needed
to push through that initial nervousness
and let you guys see what I had been
doing to get tot to do it you know so I
had that experience with Josh and Val if
you guys guys Josh
and me and a me and El are like running
the routine downstairs in the space just
in front of Josh and B like if you know
Josh he's just sort of a was this last
year German I don't know yeah it must
have been when they were here or the
time before that I don't know somewhere
when they were here and uh we were so
intimidated holy moly like
apologizing like apologizing the entire
time sorry oh jeez oh we're sorry yeah I
don't feel so much like that for the
flow show until this year I feel pretty
prepared in most of the routine I'm
actually doing three acts in the flow
show I don't know how that happened but
it's it's
happened I know why it happened and
because Noel loves putting routines
together with his friends and that is
really cool and something I admire I do
like putting routines together with my
friends I feel like it's a really good
opportunity to remember a point in time
in your life where you shared a moment
with
somebody it's pretty cool yeah yeah yeah
what else we got on this thing here flow
Show and Tell vtg again oh the the new
newer vtg discussions oh with our
transition States oh man I don't know if
we have time for what time is it it's
7:50 I feel like we should discuss
alternate topics so let's go ahead and
talk about you guys will have to wait
for that one yeah that one might have to
be a little more specialized by you guys
I mean the one person who's watching
this there is nobody watching this how
could there be people are G watch to
each other I know totally this is good
this is exactly what I'm looking for
it's just like just talking having fun
it's kind of you know the Loft show
concept yeah and it's ironic because
there is a loft right back there and we
call shows when we watch TV from the bed
to the screen we call it Loft show yeah
isn't that trippy no we're like walking
dead and Sons of Anarchy best shows ever
oh man okay walking dead last week what
do you guys say I don't know this was
kind of a kind of nothing happening yeah
Walking Dead plays the formula of Let's
Build It Up with a super boring kind of
nothing happens episode and then the
episode following is just like zombies
heads getting squished in car trunks and
people getting shot
out and just it all happens at once it's
like a big storm and then calm um it was
pretty boring last time not to say Noel
fell asleep in the middle of the fell
asleep on the floor and we all kind of
just filed out silently as Noel slept on
the floor just totally passed out on the
floor very cute I had a really awesome
like geometric pillow that aen got me oh
wait we also have this other discussion
topic which is this thing so I got this
really cool puzzle
um actually Cassie reminded me that I
was super shady and I told her i' give
her a puzzle for Christmas and I must
have given it to somebody else I was
away for Christmas okay yeah she was
somewhere else so this is a puzzle where
it's like threedimensional where you
like move this little guy it's actually
not very difficult ironically right now
looking in the screen and looking at it
it's not helping me do it any better but
what's cool about it is like parallel
sides are the same puzzle and so it's
basically like three puzzles on each
side you manipulate all three planes
through the puzzle
awesome you have to talk about the
handles the handles oh yeah oh yeah
anyway check this puzzle out I don't
know I have no idea where I bought it
but I bought like a couple of them of
like different kinds all right check it
out it's right there you lost your
chance okay here I'll float it by
again all right so I was thinking you
know it' be cool if people watch this
sometimes so we were thinking like how
could we generate viewership so if like
the Facebook page I'm just going to
randomly choose a person on there
there's no method to it it's not a
raffle I'm close your eyes and be like
yeah exactly like
uh
[Laughter]
nothing anyways it's a joke sorry wow
was gonna say it but I did it anyways we
got these handles right here these
handles are from Charlie Cushing and
Annie's company Lantern Smith Lantern
Smith and uh they glow and they have
little holes in them right here you can
peep the holes and uh what we do is
we'll just look on like Loft show on
Facebook and we'll uh give them to
somebody next week how they're gonna get
to I don't know take yeah someone's
gonna mail them I don't know oh yeah
Will personally mail them I will
lovingly wrap them in bubble paper we
also are going to do this thing where me
and Cassie were testing this earlier
where we get these to show and glove
yeah so hold on let me charge him up up
here in this light up so while he's
doing that Lantern Smith's a really
sweet company they
um uh make glow-in-the-dark props which
don't need to be plugged into any sort
of electrical source they charge with
either the Sun during the day or with
this really cool um apparatus that they
built that charges it instantly and it's
called a Sprite yeah it's called a
Sprite it uh glows super bright for
about 10 minutes-ish and then ambiently
how we're going to show you for um like
hours and they're super strong props and
really fun they make stabs and hoops and
mini hoops and poy and like you see here
the and Charlie's been making things for
clubs and all sorts of neat wow they're
glowing really bright it's going to be
awesome oh yeah this
too here Cassie have
one oh my goodness who they're bbing
ready take together same okay well no
split up oh you gotta come with me I
can't it's all backwards on this thing
okay look together the same split up
right now what oh okay forget all right
so anyways let's look at these things
closer so yeah here they are glowing in
the dark and we're in front of a super
bright computer screen and they're still
glowing I just want to say they look Tad
brighter in front of this screen than
they actually are which is kind of funny
right it's interesting because I think
they're getting lit up by the
screen all right well let's just uh
check out
here all right well that was L show for
the week uh if you check it out later
you should check out L show on Facebook
and like it and we'll give these away
next week and um yeah Mikey will be here
next week and next week we're actually
moving that time to
9:30 9:30 PST I know but that's because
Mikey goes to an aerial class and he's
really really committed to the Aerial
Class that's good yeah he he's like way
more athletic he's like healthy you
know he's buff yeah he goes to the gym
and like tracks his calories and stuff
yeah yeah totally he's like hang out he
looks like my bodyguard he's
enormous but he's not I'm gonna get
thick too I just got to membership oh
yeah okay Waits Loft show check us out
later anyways take care everybody bye oh
no and broadcast